DANIEL SIEBURG: Good
afternoon, or good morning,
depending on where
you're joining us from.
My name is Daniel Sieburg.
I work on the Google News Lab.
We're a team that cares a
lot about the future of media
and news, fostering
innovation within newsrooms
around the world.
We have a site
you can check out,
g.co/newslab if you're
interested in more,
how we work with journalists
and collaborate with them
on innovative
ideas, and projects,
and all kinds of stuff.
So we're thrilled today to host
a person who probably doesn't
need an introduction, but I'm
gonna do my best to do that.
And before I do that, I wanna
thank the Talks at Google folks
for helping put this
together, and for all
of you for coming to
spend some time today,
and watching on the live stream.
Please start thinking
of some good questions.
And I warn you, they
better be good questions,
because this is a man who
knows what a good question.
But I'm not worried, because I
know that in past experience,
Googlers have some
fantastic questions.
So I encourage you to
start thinking about that.
Maybe you've already got one.
And we'll have folks come
up to the microphones here
and an ask those as we go on.
So I'm gonna try to
get this right in terms
of your early days in broadcast.
And as I understand it--
TED KOPPEL: Historic.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Historic.
OK, sure.
Yes.
As I understand it, you
started in radio with WABC?
TED KOPPEL: No, it was ABC.
DANIEL SIEBURG: ABC, OK.
You spent time in Vietnam
as a radio correspondent.
TED KOPPEL: No, I spent time in
Vietnam as a TV correspondent.
DANIEL SIEBURG: TV
correspondent, OK.
TED KOPPEL: I spent three years.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Already
getting it wrong, so we'll
try to get that back on track.
You did travel with
Richard Nixon, correct?
TED KOPPEL: I did.
DANIEL SIEBURG: In '72?
TED KOPPEL: To China.
DANIEL SIEBURG: To China.
TED KOPPEL: I actually covered
his campaign for president
in '68.
DANIEL SIEBURG: OK.
And then "Nightline" was born
in 1980, ran for 25 years.
TED KOPPEL: Still running.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Still running.
With you at the helm for 25
years out of Washington DC.
You had a chance to interview
I don't know how many
thousands of guests.
And in the reading
that I was doing,
it grew out of the Iran
hostage crisis, the show did.
So talk to me about the
early stages of what
the premise of the show was.
I think I wrote down,
when you created the show,
it was all about bringing people
together who were worlds apart.
TED KOPPEL: That was
actually a promotional line
that someone at ABC
advertising came up with.
And every once in awhile,
someone in promotion
comes up with a line
that is just perfect.
And the idea, this is back
in the very early days
of satellite technology.
We're talking about 1979.
Satellites back then
were terribly expensive.
If you wanted to buy 10 minutes
worth of satellite time,
it cost $10,000.
So the idea of bringing people
together who were worlds apart
is something that
"Nightline" specialized in,
because during the
hostage crisis,
we would have guessed
from Tehran, Moscow,
Washington talking to one
another on live television.
That is so customary and
mundane today that you all
take it for granted.
We did not.
When I was in Vietnam--
just to give you
a sense of how far we had come
along-- when I was in Vietnam,
we still used film cameras.
Which meant that when we
shot a story in the field,
I would write the script for
the piece out in the field.
Then we would have to send
the unprocessed together
with my script from wherever
we were out in the field back
to Saigon.
In Saigon, they would put
it on a plane to Tokyo.
Tokyo, it would be trans-shipped
to Los Angeles, Los Angeles
to New York.
A motorcycle courier
would pick it up at JFK,
and would take it into 7 West
66th Street here in Manhattan.
The film would
then be processed.
The processed film
would then be edited,
married with the narration
that I have done in the field,
and the piece would get on the
air 2 and 1/2 to three days
after I had done it.
DANIEL SIEBURG:
Thanks to steam power.
TED KOPPEL: Just about, yes.
So in my professional
lifetime alone,
we have come from
being out in the field
with a cameraman, a sound
man, film, shipping it back
to the United States,
having to wait
two to three days before
you could get it on the air,
to where we are today,
where everything
is essentially instantaneous.
And when we ultimately
get to the book,
that instantaneous
nature and the manner
in which it opens
up worlds, but also
makes us terribly vulnerable
to certain things, that's
something that we will in a
little while be getting to.
DANIEL SIEBURG:
Yeah, and I will get
into your book, and the
idea that the internet could
be used as a weapon of mass
destruction essentially.
TED KOPPEL: Right.
DANIEL SIEBURG: The book
does come out today.
It's out today.
TED KOPPEL: It is out.
DANIEL SIEBURG: It's available
on Amazon or any other book
retailer.
And I would love to know,
what got you thinking about it
that much, because
it's a topic that has
been talked about quite a bit.
I would say that obviously
federal and state authorities
are aware of
something happening,
but this really feels
like the first time
it's been dug into this deeply,
and perhaps scared people
as much as it does.
TED KOPPEL: Well, we are
treated almost every day
to one account or another of
a successful hacking attack.
Whether that's a
hack into a bank,
or into a chain of
stores like Target,
or whether it's hacking
into the personal email
account of the director of the
Central Intelligence Agency
as happened just a short
time ago, all of these things
are either grand larceny,
or in the case of backing
of the records of 21 and a
half or 22.1 million members
of the federal workforce going
back any number of years,
a huge vacuuming
our intelligence.
However bad that may be,
and however dangerous
that may be to the security
of the United States,
it doesn't begin to match
the danger of a cyber attack
against one of our
power grids, which
has the capability
of taking down
the electric power for tens
of millions of Americans
over a period of weeks, months.
One estimate by a group
of 10 former officials,
senior officials, among them
two Secretaries of Defense,
to Directors of Central
Intelligence, two
of the White House advisers,
national security advisers.
They sent a letter to a
congressional committee warning
back in 2010 that a cyber
attack on the power grid
could take out the power
for millions of Americans
for up to two years.
Imagine for a moment what the
consequences of that would be.
You asked in your
question what it
was that got me
started on the book.
What got me started on
the book is the fact
that the President
has been warning
about this in two of his
State of the Union addresses.
Former Secretary of Defense
Leon Panetta warned about it,
and referred to as potentially
a cyber Pearl Harbor.
Janet Napolitano, as she
retired from her post
as Secretary of the Department
of Homeland Security,
after five years in that
job, warned about it.
And the bottom line was,
nobody has paid any attention.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Now, why
do you think that is?
I mean, is it a
bit of human nature
of waiting until there's some
sort of disaster to respond
to something?
Is it that people don't
understand it enough?
TED KOPPEL: As a former director
of the NSA, Keither Alexander,
put it to me, he said everybody,
deals with the alligators
that they're fighting
at the moment.
You got the ISIS alligator.
You got the economy alligator.
You've got the national
debt alligator.
You've got the Syrian
refugees alligator.
So somebody comes along and
says, you know, sir, pardon me,
but it's entirely possible that
a cyber attack on the power
grid, not only
possible, it's likely.
The chairman of CENTCOM,
the commander of CENTCOM,
a 4 star general by the name
of Lloyd Austin said to me,
it's not a question of if,
it's a question of when.
Once you accept
that-- forgive me.
I'll stop in a moment.
Once you accept that, then you
have to come up with answers.
You have to come
up with solutions.
And quite frankly,
at the moment,
the federal government does
not have either answers
or solutions.
The great internet
theorist Peter Neumann
said the internet was never
designed to be defended.
And you cannot put defensive
measures on to something like
the internet, which was
never designed to be defended
in the first place.
The internet is vulnerable.
And we can get into vulnerable
from whom, if you want to.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Yeah, I
absolute wanted to do that.
I just wanna dive
into the probability,
and why is there still debate
around whether this is possible
or not?
Because it seems
like in the book,
you reference a number of
fairly high level officials
who still say,
well, no, we don't
think this is possible
because of the way
the electrical
grid is structured,
and the way that
it's not connected
to the internet in certain
places of the world.
I just would love to
know your sense of that.
TED KOPPEL: Let me put
it to you this way.
In a large survey that was
done a couple years ago,
the question was raised,
are you absolutely sure
that President Obama was born
outside the United States?
And I believe it was
39% of respondents
said they were absolutely
sure that Obama was
born outside the United States.
My contention is that
in the kind of divided,
partisan country that
we live in today,
convincing all people
of any one thing
is almost impossible,
no matter how simple.
Take a look at the
issue of climate change.
And again, in a survey they
found that 92% of Democrats
believe in climate change,
and something like only 17%
of Republicans believe it.
Well, this shouldn't be
a partisan issue, right?
DANIEL SIEBURG: You make
reference to this in the book,
because you talked about
the media and their role
in all of this.
What do you think
the responsibility
is of the media on
an issue like this?
TED KOPPEL: I think the
media these days-- let
me put it to you very simply.
When I was young a foreign
correspondent with ABC News,
ABC News had about 35
foreign correspondents
based around the world.
And when I say based, I
mean living in countries
that we covered.
Many of us were
required to learn
the languages of the
country's that we covered.
Over the course of
the past 20 years,
almost all of those
bureaus have been shut down
for reasons of economy.
Maintaining a foreign bureau
costs a great deal of money,
and the networks, for
example, have discovered
that the public would
much rather have
news on the Kardashians, on
the state of the weather,
on the state of any number
of things that they can cover
far less expensively than
sending foreign correspondents
overseas.
The end result has been that,
I think, the American public,
despite the fact that we have
more information out there
today than has
ever been available
before, the degree of certainty
that the consuming public has
about that information is
frequently guided by whatever
their partisan point
of view happens to be,
rather than the kind of
objectivity which existed
far more about 40 years
ago when you only had three
networks, and
essentially Americans
gathered around the flickering
hearth of television
every evening
about 6:30 or 7:00,
and people like Walter Cronkite,
and David Brinkley, and Chet
Huntley, and Frank Reynolds,
and Howard K Smith were accepted
as being more or less objective
arbiters of what was
important out there.
Now, for all the
benefits of information
coming from 1,000
different sources,
you also have the
attendant uncertainty
of conflicting
information, and not
for people not being sure as
to whom to whom they should
believe, and that belief
factor frequently being
tied more to the partisan
credentials of the person
delivering the information
than to their objectivity
as a journalist.
DANIEL SIEBURG: I
can't promise that we
can do what you've
asked, but I would
love you to turn your sights
on Google for a minute,
and think about what should
Google do, or any other tech
company for that matter, as
pertains to this kind of issue?
TED KOPPEL: Can't help you.
DANIEL SIEBURG: OK.
TED KOPPEL: I don't know if the
name Will Rogers means anything
to you.
Any of you remember Will Rogers?
Will Rogers was the Oklahoma
cowboy in the 1920s and '30s.
He was the Jon
Stewart of his day.
He was a very witty,
very wise man.
And one of my favorite quotes
is an old Will Rogers quote
that we are all ignorant,
just about different things.
You're a very smart
bunch of people.
You wouldn't be working
for Google if you weren't.
But there are any number of
things that you know absolutely
nothing about, and
I am frank to admit
that I know next to nothing
about what you do here
at Google.
So I won't presume to tell you.
DANIEL SIEBURG: All right.
So the book is broken out into
different parts, if you will.
So there's the actual
attack, and what
might happen in a situation of
trying to retaliate or discover
where it originated,
and that kind of thing.
There's the idea
of the country not
at all being prepared for this,
and what is either being done,
or not being done.
And then there's the
aftermath, and so as soon
as the title suggests, it's
very much laid out in that way.
Which pieces of
that were perhaps
the most shocking or surprising
in terms of what you discovered
with all of this research?
TED KOPPEL: Well, I realized
that there was no point
in writing the book if I
couldn't-- and let me just back
off and explain to you something
about the nature of being
a reporter.
Almost by definition,
all the people
that I tend to cover
on stories that I cover
know more about that
particular issue than I do.
They are specialists.
I'm a generalist.
And I began the story by
knowing next to nothing
about the power grid,
about the manner in which the
power grid could be attacked.
But one of the advantages of
being a journalist in America
is it gives you the privilege
of going to the smartest
people in the country
on any given area,
and talking to them at
length about these issues.
So the first thing
that I set out to do
was satisfy myself that the
danger that Leon Panetta had
spoken of, the danger that
the President referenced,
the danger that those 10
national security leaders had
referenced in their
letter to Congress,
that was a real danger,
that genuinely existed.
And all I can tell you is
there comes a certain point
in reporting a story when
you've talked to 20, 30,
50, 60 people on
the same subject.
And yes, as Daniel
pointed out, there
was some disagreement,
but not much.
By and large, there is
almost unanimity on the fact
that the power
grid is vulnerable,
that at least the Chinese
and the Russians have already
penetrated the power
grid, that they
have what amounts to cyber
landmines planted in the power
grid, and that they
could, essentially
with the stroke of
a key, shut down all
or at least part
of a power grid.
We only have three in the
United States, the Eastern
Interconnect, which covers
the entire East Coast all
the way to the Midwest.
Texas has its own power
grid, and then there's
the West Coast.
If you could knock out
any one of those three,
or even a major portion
of one of those three,
you would be affecting the
lives of tens of millions
of Americans.
And the estimate
is that the power
could be out for weeks, months,
up to a couple of years.
That, it seems to me,
is a significant story.
And so I set out to find
out the other half of that.
What, if anything, has the
federal government done?
And the answer is
essentially nothing.
DANIEL SIEBURG: And
there's that piece of it.
So there's what the federal
government has done,
and then on the other side,
the surviving or the aftermath
part, which is very much in
the hands of the individuals,
in many ways decide
what they would
choose to do on their own.
And you talk about
what the Mormon
community has done to prepare
for some scenario like this.
TED KOPPEL: Yeah,
I spent three days
in Salt Lake City talking to
the leadership of the Mormon
Church.
And then they arranged
for me to be shown around
to make me aware
of the preparations
that they have made
as individual families
and as an organized church.
It is amazing.
I don't want to suggest to
you that they've done it
because they think there's gonna
be an attack on the power grid.
They've done it because Mormons
have been driven from pillar
to post for the past
200 years, being driven
from New York to Pennsylvania
to Ohio to Illinois, and finally
out to Salt Lake City.
And it is simply a
part of their ethos
that they prepare for disaster,
whatever that disaster may be.
Well, they've done it
at the family level.
They have done it at
the community level.
the national level.
They have warehouses
in Salt Lake City that
would put Walmart to shame.
They have, just to
give you a sense,
they have their own
trucking company,
the Deseret Trucking Company,
all driven by Mormon drivers.
And to keep that
trucking company going,
they have got reserves of
250,000 gallons of diesel fuel.
They are ready.
I am not saying that what
the Mormon Church has done
can be duplicated by
other organizations
around the United States,
but there are some things
they have done that can be.
Every Mormon family is advised,
even instructed-- I mean,
it's not a matter of faith.
You don't have to do it.
But most Mormon
families keep a supply
of three months worth of
food and water in the house,
three months worth.
It's easier to do,
obviously, when
you live in a rural community.
That kind of thing is very
difficult to do if you live,
for example, here in New York.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Well,
I think that was
exposed most recently with super
storm Sandy, which came ashore.
The power went out, especially
in this neighborhood and south.
And even though it
was only for-- I
think it was like a day
or a day and a half,
it really shined a light
on how people couldn't
charge their phones,
couldn't talk
to anybody they needed to
talk to, get coffee, I mean,
all these sort of day to day
things we take for granted.
TED KOPPEL: And little things,
for example, like, all right,
so you're gonna hop in your car.
You're gonna gas
it up, and you're
gonna drive to the next state
where the electricity is still
on.
What happened during
super storm Sandy
is they found that a
lot of gas stations
couldn't run their
pumps, because there
was no electricity.
Well, they can turn on the
emergency power generator,
right?
Most of them didn't
have generators.
Most of them, to this day,
don't have generators.
I went to my local gas station
in Potomac Maryland, talked
to the owner, said did
you buy a power generator?
He said no.
He said, they're
about 40, $50,000.
And frankly, my lease is
only for another eight years,
and there's no way
that I can envision
earning all of that money back.
Well, I said, but what
happens if the power goes out?
Well, if the power goes
out, the power goes out.
I'm out of business.
There is this fatalism about it.
But many of the
assumptions that we
make, the assumption
that we can just
drive to a nearby rural state,
and they'll take us in, well,
imagine if what we're
talking about is Manhattan.
And you're talking about five,
or six, or 8 million people
leaving Manhattan, and looking
for shelter, food, water,
and it may be that Connecticut
is out, and New Jersey is out,
and Pennsylvania is out,
so you keep on driving.
But when a community is suddenly
inundated by tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands
of domestic refugees,
if you are just
assuming that they're
gonna be taken in, I can
tell you-- I can't tell you
the name of the state,
because the person who
told me is terrified that the
governor is gonna find out,
but a rural state I know of,
not too far from Washington DC,
the Governor called in
the police, the state
police, the National Guard,
and they set up a plan.
And the plan is when those
refugees from Washington
come streaming in our direction,
we have them a sandwich,
bottle of water, and a map
to the nearest gas station,
but keep them going.
Tell them they can't stay here.
DANIEL SIEBURG: This is
analogous to what's happening
in Syria, I feel like.
It's not quite the
same way, obviously.
TED KOPPEL: You hate to think
that we would have scenes
like that, but if you're dealing
with 5, 10, 15 million people
who need food, if
your assumption
is that the state of
New York, for example,
the state of New
York does have meals
ready to eat by the million.
I don't know how many
million they have,
but I talked to the head of the
Department of Homeland Security
for the state of New York.
I think he told me
it was something
like 18 or 20 million.
So let's assume
you're just taking
care of the residents of
New York City, Manhattan.
8 million people,
18 million MREs.
OK, you're good for
the first three days.
Then what are you gonna do?
And you cannot replace
MRE as quickly.
I mean, the food
has to be grown,
the food has to be
harvested, and MREs
expire after five years.
So governments are reluctant
to buy large quantities of MREs
in advance of a
disaster, because they
figure the MREs are goonna go
past their expiration date.
So there are problems that
very few people have even
begun to think
about that I believe
we really need to confront,
and need to deal with.
DANIEL SIEBURG: It
sounds like admitting
this is an issue is perhaps the
first step, or addressing it.
What do you hope would
be the response to this?
I mean, I'm sure people
will read the book
and think, oh my gosh.
I can't build a safe house.
I don't know if I can store
three months of supplies.
And then you've got
government officials
that seem to be a little
bit all over the place.
What do you hope at least starts
out of something like this?
TED KOPPEL: Well, I
mean, you're right.
You can't just from
day one to day three
get three months
worth of supplies.
But you can begin every time
you go shopping every week,
buying a little bit
more than you need.
You can begin to put
enough water into the house
that least you've
got something that'll
take you through the
first couple of weeks.
You can begin by looking.
I mean, we have wonderful
portable filtration systems
right now that would
quite literally allow
you to take water out of the
East River, or the Hudson
River, and process
it, and drink it.
If you don't have water,
if the power goes out
in a place like
Manhattan, it's not
just that the lights go out.
It's not just that the
heating or cooling goes out.
It's not just that you have
no refrigeration or heating
in the winter.
It's also that you
can't flush the toilets,
because the water
is being pumped,
and the pumps are being
run by electricity.
When the water goes out,
all of a sudden, you've
got a community of 6,
7, 8 million people,
and there's no waste disposal.
That is a huge health crisis.
These are all issues that
need to be confronted.
And I'm simply saying
until we acknowledge
the likelihood of something
like this happening,
we're not gonna begin
coming up with solutions.
And that, if I
understand correctly,
what people at Google do, coming
up with solutions for problems
is one of the things
you specialize in.
So I would be thrilled
if even a few of you
took the danger seriously, and
began to approach it, and come
up with solutions.
DANIEL SIEBURG: As a society,
we've gotten very comfortable
in the 21st century.
We don't really think about
all of those convenience.
We can come back to
the book at any point.
If you'd like, I would
love to just steer you
in a slightly
different direction.
TED KOPPEL: Any
direction whatsover.
DANIEL SIEBURG: This is a
very open ended question,
and I apologize.
But I would just love to get
your sense of the challenges
and opportunities for
the future of news.
I mean, how you see it, both
from a production standpoint,
but from a consumer standpoint.
Are we better informed?
Do we have more opportunities?
Is it more confusing?
Where do you see the
future of news going?
TED KOPPEL: I think
it is more confusing.
I mean, it's almost quaint
today to look back 20 years
and say, there was a time when
Walter Cronkite, the anchor
of the CBS Evening News, was
considered to be the most
trusted man in America.
If I were to say
to you today, just
yell out the name of
a trusted news figure,
you'd probably come
up with Jon Stewart
before you'd come
up with anybody
who's doing the network news.
And the problem when you have
quite literally thousands
of sources of news is
being able to establish
the veracity of what any one of
these sources is putting out.
And when the way that we tend
to judge these different outlets
is as often not, on a basis
of what their ideology is,
that's a very iffy way of
establishing what's accurate
and what's not accurate, what's
reliable and what's unreliable.
It is, I think, one of the
great paradoxes of our time
that we live in an era where
there is more information being
communicated more quickly
across greater distances
than ever before in
the history of mankind,
and yet, the American
public as a whole
does not appear to be
increasingly well informed
as a consequence of that.
In fact, the tendency to hold
onto-- to be so attached to Fox
on the right or MSNBC on
the left, or Rush Limbaugh,
or whoever it may be
that is putting out
something that
resonates to the biases
that the listener or
viewer already harbors.
That's unhealthy.
And I wish I could see the way
clear to finding a path back
to having some
generally accepted
sources of objective news.
That's hard to find these days.
DANIEL SIEBURG: I wanna mention
a few people who have either
been a guest on your show
or in your life in some way,
and just get your
reaction to them.
I don't know how you would
describe your relationship
with this person,
but Henry Kissinger.
What's a conversation
like with him?
TED KOPPEL: We're friends.
I mean, I have known Doctor
Kissinger for 40 years.
I covered his shuttle diplomacy.
I understand the rap on him.
I believe him to be a
genuine patriot with some
of whose policies
I may disagree,
but I think he tried very hard
to do what he believed to be
best for the United States.
He is to this day-- and I think
he's now 93 or 94 years old.
There are some people,
when you sit down and talk
to them after about 20 minutes,
your head begins to ache,
because they're so
far ahead of you.
That is still true of Kissinger.
He is one of the very
smartest people I know.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Morrie Schwartz.
You can tell the story for
folks who don't know him.
TED KOPPEL: Sure,
Morrie Schwartz
was a sociology professor
at Brandeis who came down
with Lou Gehrig's disease.
And someone in the
Boston Globe did a piece
on Professor
Schwartz, and the fact
that he had invited his
former students and friends
to come back and see
him on a regular basis,
because he just wanted
to talk to them.
And I did a "Nightline" program
on Morrie Schwartz, which
was seen by a sports
columnist for the-- I
think it's the
Detroit Free Press.
And he suddenly
realized that I was
talking about his old sociology
professor at Brandeis.
And he proceeded
to contact Morrie,
and went back to see
him, and then proceeded
for the rest of Morrie's life
to go to see him every Tuesday.
And that book by Mitch
Albom was known as "Tuesdays
with Morrie."
I loved Morrie Schwartz.
I mean, he was just
an extraordinary man.
I'll give you one insight
into Morrie Schwartz.
He was dying, dying of this
terrible, terrible disease,
where all the muscles
atrophy so that first you
can't move your legs.
Then you can't move your hands,
and then you can't swallow.
And ultimately, you die.
And Morrie said, look.
I know you're gonna have
a memorial service for me
after I die.
And he said, I won't be here
to see it, so what I wanna do
is I wanna have a
memorial service for me
while I'm still alive.
And all of my friends
and relatives can come.
And he did.
He had himself laid down
on the kitchen table
with a bunch of
lilies on his chest.
And his friends just got up, and
started saying wonderful things
about him.
And when you think
about it, it's
actually a hell of a lot nicer.
I mean, one of the terrible
things about your funeral
is you're not gonna be
able to enjoy it, right?
And Morrie actually
enjoyed his own funeral.
But that book has
now been translated
into dozens of languages.
It's been turned into
a theater production.
It's been turned into a movie.
And I'm privileged
to have known him.
He was a remarkable man.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Nelson Mandela.
There's a particular interview
you did with him after he
was released from prison.
TED KOPPEL: It is a matter
of some dispute between Dan
Rather and me as to which of
us got the first interview
with Morrie.
But let's say Dan got it, and
I got the second interview.
He is Nelson Mandela.
He is, in some respects
when you think about it,
a perfect example of why it
is so hard-- let me back off--
DANIEL SIEBURG: You can
set the stage of what
that interview was like too.
TED KOPPEL: I will, and I'll
tell you in just a moment.
If I were to say to you, let's
go back to the 1930s and '40s,
and shout out the names of
some great men and women
without regard to whether it
was a great good or great evil,
you could come up with
Churchill, and Roosevelt,
and Stalin, and Mao, and Gandhi.
I mean, you can just keep going.
If I were to say to
you today, shout out
the name of the two
or three great people,
one of the only
names a few years ago
that you might
have come up with--
and I'm ready to be astonished
if you start yelling out
some names right now.
Please feel free to do so--
one of the few people who
met that definition
was Nelson Mandela.
And I have a theory about that.
Part one of the theory is, yes,
he was a genuinely great man.
Anyone who can survive 26
years in a South African prison
under the worst
days of Apartheid,
and to come out with such
generosity of spirit,
is a truly great man.
But there is another
aspect of that.
And that is for 26 years, you
did not see Nelson Mandela.
You did not hear Nelson Mandela.
You did not know what
Nelson Mandela was thinking.
Nelson Mandela was
removed from public view.
And I'm convinced that
one of the reasons
that we have such a
hard time these days
coming up with the
name of anybody great
is that as soon
as someone begins
to rise to the
level of greatness,
somebody out there does a blog.
Somebody out there you know
reveals some piece of nastiness
about that man or woman.
And being able to
rise to greatness
in the current atmosphere
of constant 24 hour a day
surveillance is
almost impossible.
So I think Nelson Mandela--
I believe Nelson Mandela was
a great man, but I
also think that being
out of sight, in prison,
actually helped his
being perceived as a great man.
DANIEL SIEBURG:
Sure, and I would
love for you to talk about
that particular interview too.
I mean, I wouldn't say
that it was contentious.
That's probably
not the right word.
But it was--
TED KOPPEL: Or, no.
I think you're thinking
about another--
I interviewed Nelson Mandela
in William Mandela's backyard
in Soweto just after he
had come out of prison.
DANIEL SIEBURG:
Yeah, I'm thinking
in front of this crowd.
TED KOPPEL: The
contentious interview
that I did with
Nelson Mandela was
done about 100 blocks uptown.
And I did a town meeting
with Nelson Mandela
here in New York in front of a
largely African-American crowd.
And I started pressing
in on the issue of some
of his friendships
with the Cubans,
and with communists in
Vietnam, and asking him
about the
appropriateness of that.
And he began by saying,
I think I know better
than you, Mr. Koppel.
And the crowd erupted.
I mean, people
standing, and cheering,
and whistling, and
absolutely loving watching
Nelson Mandela crush me.
I mean, it was a great moment.
DANIEL SIEBURG: It
was a bit of a-- yeah,
like a bit of a boxing match.
TED KOPPEL: Absolutey.
He was.
He was a great man.
DANIEL SIEBURG: I wanna
encourage people to come up
to the microphones too.
If you have questions,
we've got about another--
TED KOPPEL: And listen,
it's been my experience
that nobody wants to
ask the first question.
So let's skip the
first question,
go right to the second question.
DANIEL SIEBURG: I just
have a couple more for you.
One, I would love to
get a sense of what
it was like seeing your
daughter Andrea as a journalist.
She was at CNN for many years.
TED KOPPEL: Many years.
DANIEL SIEBURG:
What was that like,
seeing her too come up from--
TED KOPPEL: I have to
tell you, my oldest
daughter Andrea, who now
works for Mercy Corps,
and is now on the side of the
angels, worked for many years
for CNN.
She speaks fluent
Chinese, so she
was the Beijing bureau
chief for a while,
and then went to the
State Department,
and then covered the House.
She wanted desperately to
avoid becoming a journalist.
She hated the idea of
being a journalist.
She went to Beijing
as a business woman,
and had a miserable time, and
finally came back one day,
and said, you know,
Dad, the only people
who seem to be having
any good time at all
are the journalists.
And I wanna start--
I'm gonna start over.
I wanna be a journalist.
And so I said to her, well,
you gotta learn the trade.
And so she spent a year in South
Carolina working for a National
Public Radio station.
Then she worked in Baltimore for
about a year, year and a half,
then went down to Miami.
And then one day,
CNN called and said,
you know, our
Beijing bureau chief
is resigning or
moving on, and we need
someone who speaks Chinese.
And we understand
you speak Chinese.
And so that was the
beginning of that.
And to answer your question,
enormously proud is how I feel.
DANIEL SIEBURG: That's great.
TED KOPPEL: Sir.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: First
question is, how do you
know if the people you talk
to are not exaggerating?
Because everybody has an agenda.
TED KOPPEL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And saying
the power grid will
be down for two years assumes
that everybody will just
start crying instead of
trying to solve things.
But there are many
technical way of solving
any technical problem, and
this is a technical problem
if it would happen.
So how do you know
that we are not--
You wrote a book on an
exaggerated disaster.
I'm not saying the
disaster will not
happen, but maybe to
exaggerated by the situation.
TED KOPPEL: Maybe.
And if that turns out to be
the case, then mea culpa.
But I would rather be in a
position of-- first of all,
I've been a reporter now
for well over 50 years.
If you'll pardon
my crude language,
I have an excellent
bullshit detector.
It is one of the things
you learn as a journalist.
I can usually tell
when I'm being spun.
And when the number
of people that I
talk to at the level of the
people that I spoke to-- I
mean, you're gonna have
to explain to me what
possible advantage at
the moment Barack Obama
can derive from speaking
about the danger of a cyber
attack against the power grid.
What's his motive
for doing that?
What advantage does he
derive from doing that?
Yes, and I write
about it in the book,
it is possible that people
bring their expertise
from government, and then they
open up a cyber consulting
firm, and make a
great deal of money.
But you cannot deny the fact
that every single day hundreds
if not thousands of
organizations are being hacked.
That's a reality.
That's not something
that's being made up.
Why do you think that of all
the industries out there,
the only one that
is immune to hacking
is the power industry,
particularly when
the power industry
has been deregulated,
so that it is not
subject to a great deal
of federal regulation.
Parts of it are not subject
to any federal regulation.
There are 3,200
electric power companies
in this country today.
The biggest and the wealthiest
have extraordinary protections
against hacking.
The smallest and
the poorest do not.
They are all interconnected.
If you hack into one, eventually
if you know what you're doing,
you can get into
the biggest ones.
That's what I spent the
better part of a year doing,
is trying to answer
exactly that question.
You may be right.
I may be wrong.
I don't think so.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DANIEL SIEBURG: All right.
We'll go to this side.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being
here, Mr. Koppel, by the way.
TED KOPPEL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just concerning
the landscape of journalism,
as you referenced earlier, do
you see any newer outlets that
are a little bit of a light?
Just for example, anything like
the Young Turks organization
or Vice News, or anything
that's relatively new,
do you see any of
that as positive
and maybe going in
the right direction
as far as integrity goes?
TED KOPPEL: Look, I
must confess to you.
I'm not a bit of an old fogey.
I'm an old fogey.
AUDIENCE: You're
the man, Mr. Koppel.
TED KOPPEL: I still read
three newspapers a day.
I listen to NPR in the morning.
I watch BBC, and CBS,
NBC in the evening.
I do not spend a great
deal of time scanning
the internet for some
of these smaller outfits
that you're talking about.
So I'm one of the
least qualified people
around to comment on
how viable they are.
What is absent in
this country today--
and you see it reflected
in this wild political year
that we're going
through-- is a sense
that there are
half a dozen people
out there, 10 people
out there, 20 people out
there, in the whom we can have
a little bit of confidence
that they are trying very hard
to be objective reporters.
I don't doubt for
a moment that there
are some of these
organizations out there.
How many people do they reach?
Is there anybody
left in America today
of whom we can
say, yes, Americans
of all stripes, Republicans
Democrats, liberals,
conservatives, all turn
to this man or woman,
and say we have
confidence in that person?
I don't see those people
out there anymore.
Do you?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
TED KOPPEL: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hence the question.
TED KOPPEL: Yes, sir.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious in knowing
what brought this particular
interest in the power grid
to you.
Because I've never heard
about those power grids.
And certainly we all talk
about hacking banks and things
like that, but what caused
that particular interest
in investigating more
about a possible attack
into power grids.
TED KOPPEL: I'll tell you
the whole dirty story.
First of all, I had, as
I said at the outset,
I had read some of these
extraordinary statements.
I mean, when a sitting
Secretary of Defense
warns a group of,
I think they were,
defense contractors in a speech
here in New York about a cyber
Pearl Harbor, there is
no more dramatic image
that an American
official can call up.
So I heard that.
I heard what Janet
Napolitano had to say.
And I saw nothing happening
as a consequence of that.
So I was sitting on my porch one
afternoon, looking out, saying,
what the hell would I do if the
power went out, and stayed out?
We live on a beautiful
piece of property.
We have deer.
We have wild turkey.
So I thought, well, I
could always shoot a deer.
And then I thought,
well, I don't have a gun.
well, I could get a gun.
All right, well, would I
get lucky and shoot a deer?
Fine, let's assume
I can shoot a deer.
Now I have to gut it, and
skin it, and prepare it.
And the more I thought
about it, the more
I realized that I was
totally unprepared to deal
without the comforts
of an electric grid.
That's when I got on
the phone and started
calling the Department of
Homeland Security, the Red
Cross, FEMA, and
saying, well, actually I
wasn't able to say
anything, because I
couldn't talk to anyone.
Try it one of these
days, just for fun.
Pick up the phone, and
call the Red Cross,
and say this idiot Koppel has
just scared the crap out of me,
and told me that
there's a chance that we
will be without power
for weeks or even months.
What do I do?
See if you get an answer.
See if you get any
kind of an answer.
I predict you won't.
So that's how it came to be.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious.
Did you change your
behavior as a result of--
did you buy a gun, by the way?
TED KOPPEL: No, I did not.
I mean, my wife-- somehow I have
a hard time envisioning my wife
and me cradling a
couple of shotguns,
waiting for the starving
hordes to come up and--
AUDIENCE: But did you yourself
find ways in your life
to accommodate something?
TED KOPPEL: Yes.
I mean, as I say,
we live in an area
where the power goes out a
lot, so we have generators.
We have a couple of
large generators.
I did, because of what I told
you about meals ready to eat,
and the fact that they're only
good for, like, five years,
I have now bought
for my wife and me,
and for our children
and grandchildren,
freeze dried food sufficient
to last for a couple of months.
And we will have
water in the house
sufficient to last for
a couple of months.
Am I putting up barbed wire
fences or hiring some ex-SEALs?
No.
But I will tell you, there
are people here in New York
who have done just that.
I know of one family
that hired a SEAL.
They have a boat that is moored
in somewhere on the Hudson.
And if and when this happens,
they plan to get on that boat,
take it out to a larger boat
that is moored away offshore,
and then go to one
of the islands.
But that's the kind of
thing that only the very
wealthy and psychotic can do.
DANIEL SIEBURG: That's
a lethal combination,
wealthy and psychotic.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Going back to the state of
journalism, I was wondering--
TED KOPPEL: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Going back to
the state of journalism,
I was wondering if
you could give us
your perspective on the
perception I have and I think
a lot of people have that the
media has come to not challenge
public figures as much as they
used to about things they say
in the interest of
being balanced, instead
of challenging what
sometimes are fairly obvious
mistakes of fact.
So what do you think?
Have you seen that transition?
Is that something
you agree with?
TED KOPPEL: What you're
saying is interesting,
because on the one
hand, you're right.
And I think your
perception is right.
On the other hand, everybody
is being challenged
with a level of vitriol that
has never existed-- well,
I don't want to
say never existed,
but hasn't existed, for example,
in my lifetime experience,
by the opposition.
So that when you're listening
to the extreme right talking
about a Democrat,
or the extreme left
talking about a Republican,
particularly a Tea Party
Republican-- I mean, you
talk about challenging,
they challenge every
word that is being said.
But it's dismissed because
it's the political position.
What is missing in journalism
today, I would argue,
is the sense of
finding people who
are generally accepted
as reasonable people
with objectivity.
Excuse me.
People who are
reasonably objective,
and whose objectivity
is widely accepted.
That, I find, all
but disappearing now.
I mean, the only time that
people on the far right
will accept something
that's in the New York
Times, for example, is if
it confirms some suspicion
that they've had to begin with.
But the notion that
there are still
generally acceptable pillars
of journalism out there,
whose writing or whose
narration is accepted?
I'm sorry, I think it's missing.
DANIEL SIEBURG: I will--
just go back to the question
previously about where
journalism is headed,
I'll push back a
little bit, and say I
think we've seen some exciting
entities come up, whether it's
Vice Media, or Vox, or
data driven journalism,
and that kind of thing.
I mean, pushing some of the
ways of telling stories.
TED KOPPEL: Let's take
Vice as an example.
And I agree with you.
And I watch Vice.
And I think Vice has
done some really superb
investigative journalism.
Terrific.
But how many pieces do
they put on the air, right?
What you had with the
networks in their golden days,
in the halcyon days,
ironically, you
didn't have as many
programs as you have today,
but that half hour of
news in the evening
covered a wide, wide
variety of subjects.
I agree with you.
I think Vice does
some excellent work,
but the number of subjects that
they're capable of covering
over the course of a year?
Very limited.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Sure.
And you're right.
Audiences are very fractured.
they've got so many choices.
We're pretty much out of time.
So Ted, I know that
you're going to be
signing some books for folks.
TED KOPPEL: OK.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Last
thing if I can ask you,
who's doing it right today?
I mean, who's a person that
you admire, who you watch,
or you see in news?
An anchor, a
reporter, somebody you
think is really worth
spending your time with.
TED KOPPEL: Look, I
think my old friend
Charlie Rose is doing a
terrific job over at CBS.
I think my friends
at the PBS News Hour
are doing-- years
ago, Robin McNeil,
who helped begin the
News Hour, said to me,
we are the program
that dares to be dull.
And I said, Robin, I
think sometimes you're
a little bit too daring.
We have to find a balance
between being so dry.
I think they're
coming a long way,
and I'm delighted that
the PBS News Hour is now
being led by someone who used
to work for me at "Nightline,"
and she is doing a brilliant
job of producing that program.
So yes, there are
good people out there.
Gwen Iffil is a
terrific reporter.
And Judy Woodruff is
And they're doing a great job.
I love NPR.
I really do.
I think NPR, on balance--
a friend of mine
once described NPR as being like
the inside of an intricately
designed sweater.
You look at the outside,
and it's perfect.
The design is just lovely.
And you pull it back,
and you see all the knots
and the loose threads.
It's a weird outfit.
It really is.
But what comes out
of there is terrific.
DANIEL SIEBURG: Well,
we're delighted you
spent an hour here with us.
So please, everyone,
thanks to you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
And if you've got
additional questions,
I'm sensitive that you have
to get out at a certain time.
This is the start of a cross
country book tour or for you.
But thank you again for coming.
TED KOPPEL: My pleasure.
Thank you, Daniel.
DANIEL SIEBURG:
Thank you all too.